you grow up and were you interested in
Show Business when you were a kid did
you know I got show business in my blood
I yeah I think so I mean pretty much I
mean I think I was like I mean I did
have show business in my blood on the
Puerto Rican side of my family my girl
my great grandparent Grandparents were
um Flamenco dancers I mean it never I
was never connected to Hollywood or
anything like that but I think so I
don't know I was a really quiet kid up
until I went to like yeah until I
discovered Community Theater
I was kind of like really shy yeah like
as a younger child I was like kind of
quiet and shy and if I had talked to you
when you were like eight would you have
and I wouldn't have been allowed to talk
to you when you were eight but uh what
would would you have said yeah I'm
interested in doing anything involving
performing for people or would that have
been the furthest thing from your mind
oh it would have been like
Woods I found a skull and I know it is
of a baby
um I was into things like make-believe
that's great I found a skull follow me
into the woods you sure that was
make-believe did you find it though
maybe you want to tell us about the fort
and do a ritual because I know it's a
baby's scarf
um I like to play in the woods as an
eight-year-old come with me to the woods
wow you'd be a terrible camp counselor
well kids here's your new camp counselor
for today the new CIT Aubry is Gonna
Come with me
I found the skull of a baby there must
be a ritual that'd be fantastic I was in
a very delusional child but I I never
thought like oh I could actually do that
but I was definitely obsessed with
movies I mean I was like yeah the minute
I had my hands on a video camera in the
90s you know I was I was just making
movies all the time right which movies
did you like when you were young well I
was kind of I was never exposed to like
great films until I was a
teenager and I started working in the
video shop yep remember those yep so I
was I grew up on you know like
blockbuster movies Spielberg movies all
the all the all the big ones
Ghostbusters but
um a lot of romantic comedies yeah you
like you like the rom-com I liked weird
movies too like I I'll never forget when
I saw for the boys starring Bette Midler
you know that movie where she goes on
the is James Khan in that too yeah isn't
it like a USO tour yes and I saw they're
way too young I saw like weird movies
yeah that's not a movie for I mean not
that it's a racy movie but it's just not
amazing for kids like a nine-year-old
yeah now that's hard
James Khan Bette Midler Uso shows I
swear to God that's a movie also you
know I had a really big impact on me as
Designing Women so I discovered that
show in my the basement of my foster
grandparents house and I was not allowed
to watch that show as a young child
really oh yeah I learned a lot from that
show but how to design a sugar
Delta Burke and Cox
I didn't know that was a sexy show are
you kidding all they did was date and
talk about having sex and then I don't
know but probably with real Sly innuendo
that wasn't that hard well they were
just like real sassy southern women so
it was always you know they're always
screaming about they never seem to be
doing any work no and that's the common
theme in most shows that are about a
workplace no one's working right I mean
if you watch you know Murphy Brown
they're always sitting around at a tiny
table they're supposed to be three of
the most pop three or four of the most
powerful journalists in the world is
basically supposed to be 60 minutes and
it's supposed to be Mike Wallace and you
know all these powerful people but
they're sitting in a tiny little table
that shows them in a multi-camera
setting yeah and they're poking at
little salads and being goofballs and
nothing's getting done
I want to do a workplace comedy where
people just seriously quietly work the
whole time and there's no banter cheers
was the closest because they'd at least
be delivering drinks and things not much
not a lot okay well then I'm wrong yeah
yeah you know we worked a lot on that
show you did well you did but that was
very focused on the tasks that we were
doing the comedy came out of the not to
make it about me this isn't about me no
it's just a podcast starring you today
okay so it is about you